on finland's West Coast they've been
generating nuclear power for more than
40 years temporarily storing highly
radioactive waste in shielded bunkers
so we are going on the ground
now for the first time anywhere in the
world they're going to bury it more than
400 meters underground the Bedrock is
1.9 billion years old and studies
suggest it's an ideal nuclear tomb
the rocket shelf are like in the whole
area in Finland
as in general is very stable we have old
truck we don't have continental plates
earthquakes seismicity things like that
these tunnels will eventually stretch
for 40 miles and hold six and a half
thousand tons of spent nuclear fuel once
full they'll be back filled and the
whole complex sealed in while the
radioactivity safely decays
this is being built to last 100
000 years it is an extraordinary time
span go back that long and it's a period
of ice and mammoths and woolly rhinos
and modern humans hadn't even set foot
in Europe but that's the kind of time
scale that's required when you're
dealing with nuclear waste the waste
will be packed in double layered metal
canisters slotted into holes bored in
the floor of the tunnels they'll be
swaddled in the same absorbent material
that's used in cat litter multiple
barriers that are designed to keep
radioactivity locked in we can look in
if you come with this site so the boss
says such deep disposal is far safer
than leaving nuclear waste on the
surface
on the surface the interim storage needs
active measures from humans it needs to
be building needs to be heated
spend fuel must be cooled it must be
there must be security around it
if you look at generation forward you
cannot really
see that that kind of an arrangement
would be risk risk-free enough experts
from Britain and elsewhere are watching
finland's progress for possible sites
for burying the UK's ways to being
shortlisted in Cumbria and Lincolnshire
so we have 70 years worth of waste in
the UK that's already accumulated from
energy production defense industrial
processes and it's not going anywhere
unless we do something with it then we
have to take action to make sure this is
managed responsibly in Finland winning
over local people has been as important
as the engineering urioki is just 10
miles away but the nuclear industry is a
big employer and the mayor says support
for the waste site is high they know
nuclear and final disposal in this area
much much more than for example in the
areas we doesn't have a nuclear power
plants and and that trust has developed
during four decades Finland is decades
ahead in finding a solution for its
nuclear waste
there is a growing consensus that the
260
000 tons piled up worldwide can't be
left for future generations to clean up
Thomas More Sky News in Western Finland